يشكك الناس في وطنيتي
بأنني لا أبدو أميركيًا بما يكفي لأنهم
لا يستطيعون التغلب على هذا
الوجه ، أريد أن أريكم
شيئًا أريد أن أخبركم به لأنني لست
خائفًا ،
هذا دليلي على أن
هذا مستدام من خلال خدمتي
في الجيش الأمريكي
الآن هل هذا وطني بما فيه الكفاية
لقد كنت عاطفيًا للغاية
بعد أن خلعت قميصي ، واو أشعر
بتحسن بعد
سنوات عديدة ، حصلت عليه على صدري
بعد ذلك بعامين كنت تحت
هجومي في الشارع من قبل رجل أبيض
هو  اعتقدت
أنني كنت مصابًا باضطراب ما بعد الصدمة ، لقد كان من قدامى المحاربين في الحرب العالمية الثانية ،
وكان يعتقد أنني ياباني ،
وكان علي أن أذهب إلى المستشفى ، أعني أنه
حاول قتلي
وكان هذا هو نقطة التحول ،
لذلك كنت في حيرة من أمري
بشأن هذا البلد  ذهبت إلى
الجيش لتتعلم عن الأمريكية
[الموسيقى
] أعمل للدفاع عن حرية التعبير
الخاصة بك.
كيف يجب أن يبدو شكل
الأمريكيين  لهذا السبب كنت أقوم بتوضيح فكرة
[موسيقى
] أريد أن أخدم مجتمعي ، شعرت
أنه من واجبي أن أعيش فيه ، أريد أن
يكون لي صوت فيه ،
يحتاج الجميع إلى أن يعامل على قدم المساواة
مع كرامة واحترام
، والأهم من ذلك كله أن أحضر  عودة الكياسة
إلى مجتمعنا هنا